By these transformations,
it's possible to write any linear
program in a variety of forms.
Two forms, however, tend to be
the most convenient and widely used.
First is what we'll call
the symmetric form.
We'll see why it gets that name
when we consider duality and
second is the standard form.
The key difference between the two is
that we have changed the inequality for
an equality.
To better understand the relationship
between these two forms,
I'm going to write the standard form
in terms of the symmetric form.
To convert the m
inequalities to equalities,
we introduce n slack variables.
Xn plus 1 through xn + m.
And of course, this means that we need
to augment our matrix a as well, so
that the slack variables
can do their job.
And C also needs to be augmented, so
that we can multiply it with the new x
without changing the value
of the objective function.
It's interesting to think about
the differences between these two forms
geometrically, as well.
In the symmetric, we're optimizing
over a polytope in end dimensions.
In the standard form, however,
these equality constraints here
define something called the flat,
which is rather like a subspace, only
it's away from the origin and then we're
intersecting that with the cone defined
by the positive coordinate axes.
And of course,
we're in a higher dimension.
Note that we expect an optimum for
the symmetric problem to be at one
of the vertices of the polytope.
That is to say,
of these m plus n constraints here.
N must hold with equality or
be tight in the common products.
Some might come from A, some might come
from the non-negativity constraints,
but there will always be n of them.
Over here in standard form,
the notion of whether the constraints of
A are tight or not is captured by
the slack variables that we introduced.
A slack variable is zero if and only if,
the corresponding constraint is tight.
Thus, at least n of
the variables will be zero
when we're at a vertex of
the original polytope.
In fact, if I tell you which n variables
are zero and the ones that are nonzero
correspond to a linearly independent
set of constraints, then you can
construct the rest of the variable
based on the equality constraint.
We'll see this when we talk
about basic solutions.
Now so far, I've kept on using the
number of variable n and the number of
constraints m from the symmetric form,
even as we talk about the standard form.
In general, however,
when discussing the standard form,
we redefine n to be the old n plus m.
So don't get confused about that.
One other thing to note about this
equality form is that we can assume that
A is full rank or has rank m
where m is the number of rows.
That is the say,
the rows should be linearly independent.
If the rows aren't linearly independent,
then there are two possibilities.
One is that the constraints
are inconsistent,
meaning that there is no solution.
The other possibility is that
the constraints are redundant,
meaning that some of
them can be eliminated.
So from now on,
we'll just assume that A has full rank.